do you ever feel alone when you are
trying to grow your youtube channel do
you just wish that there could be
someone to give you some pointers and
tips on if you're even doing this
youtube thing right well today on the
growth video live show i have my special
guest and friend from vid iq helping me
here on the podcast do channel reviews
all of that is coming up on the grow
with video live show
[Music]
welcome back to the encore edition of
the grow with video live show i know you
thought that yesterday was the last one
but no no no we are here again for one
more show and we want to bless you with
some channel reviews today so if you are
watching live right now you can drop
your channel in the comment section my
team is over there grabbing those for
you and this is an open q a as well so
if you've had a burning question that
you want to ask the think media team or
the vid iq team we are here for you
today my name is heather torres one of
the hosts of the podcast here at think
media co-creator of video ranking
academy and the host of the conference
grow with video
live that is happening in just
five days i cannot believe it i am
actually in a little bit of shock that
we are almost here we have been laboring
over this for so many months and i
cannot wait for you to see the
incredible lineup that's going to be at
growth video live this year it's
happening next week do you have your
ticket are you coming in person are you
coming virtually let me know in the
comment section below and what an insane
lineup that's happening this year at
grow with video live you can claim your
ticket at growwithvideolive.com
and i have a special coupon code for you
gwvlshow.com we're going to be featuring
people like alex or mosey gary
vaynerchuk jasmine star chalene johnson
the entire think media team we've got
ryan pineda we've got uh um we've got
patrick that david so many incredible
speakers and
one of the speakers is actually joining
me today for our grow with video live
show and that is rob from vidiq vidiq is
actually one of our main sponsors of
this and i am so excited that we get to
partner with such an incredible company
and rob is an amazing teacher he's me
breaking down different pieces of how
you can be using vid iq to grow your
channel also and so i thought who better
else to bring to the growth video live
show than my friend rob from vidiq he is
one of their uh featured content
creators he's been growing this youtube
channel to over a million subscribers
he's in-depth knowledge on how youtube
works and i am so excited to have him
here again on the podcast rob welcome to
the show
hey heather thank you for having me on
once again and hello to all of you think
media rights uh i do just have one
question now that you are just five days
away
how are you feeling do you get nervous
do you get excited what's the feeling at
the moment in a think media headquarters
yeah really great actually i i have been
uh i am a woman of faith and so i have
been praying for supernatural peace and
that's actually what i feel like i feel
at so much peace with what's about to
happen we have an incredible team that
is working behind the scenes um i will
say though i was a little stressed out
my outfits the other day so i had to go
and like put them all on and make sure
they worked great but um i mean all the
speakers are excited i'm excited i would
say um you know we've planned a lot of
events this is by far the biggest event
the most expensive event but i think
this event is going to be the one with
the most breakthrough
because of people like you who are going
to be teaching at it
well i wish you a very best of luck i'm
sorry i can't be there myself in person
but i will be there virtually so do
check me out if you have time after all
of the uh highlight speakers and one
further advice i will always give to
anybody who attends a conference in
person is to make sure you network with
as many people as possible you will be
shattered after it but the what you will
gain from it and the contacts you have
will last you for months and years to
come
yeah it's so true there's going to be
massive networking and if you have the
virtual all-access pass or the vip in
person pass you're going to have access
to the recordings so if you are coming
to the conference and you miss a session
because you're networking or you just
want to re-watch like rob session or
garyvee's session or um alex or mosey's
session you'll have access to that with
those ticket levels so make sure that
you either upgrade your ticket or get
your ticket virtually or in person to be
able to have access to those different
trainings um i am so excited uh chris
are you doing channel reviews today yeah
we are chris that's what we're here for
we're doing channel reviews today um so
rob i'll let you start with the first
one but here's how this rolls uh here at
think media you can drop that you want a
channel review our team is over there
and what helps is if you say i would
like a review please and
ask a specific question because that
really helps us understand where you are
in the process of growing your channel
and how we can best serve you uh with
this channel review also if you're
requesting a channel review and you
don't get one i want to encourage you to
lean in to the teaching that rob and
myself are doing because what we're
saying for other channels it can apply
to your channel as well so your goal
today as you're watching this is to pull
out one to two things that you also want
to be improving on your channel i think
it's really uh great when you come with
an intention to learn and learn from
other people
um so that you can also grow your
channel as well so i'm excited wendy
said she's gonna be there she's gonna be
there in person uh jeff says in person
make sure you have business cards yes
jeff that's a huge one um so i'm excited
for that all right rob well let's kick
it off we've got a a handful of reviews
to do today and um if you also have a
question for us this is open q a as well
and we're here to help you get to your
first 1000 subscribers and beyond and
the reason for that is because when you
get to 1 000 subscribers and 250 000
hours of watch time you unlock the
ability to be a partner with youtube
right so we want to help you get to the
place where you can actually be um
partnering with youtube to be making
money on your channel all right rob who
do you have first you mean four thousand
hours of watch time that heavy you said
250 you said 250 000.
you you set my heart going and
everything what 250 000 equals the
amount of minutes
four hours
right yeah
well obviously i don't know numbers
today rob that is where i'm at
oh you're right 4 000 hours 250 000
minutes is what that ends up being so
we'll go with 4 000. it's a better
number
garage gym tips then is the first
channel we're looking at and a few
things to first of all congratulate you
on that you've cracked 100 subscribers
so you've unlocked your custom url which
i see you've already set up and you've
been on youtube for approximately a year
at this point and you have
i'd say in a region of 25 to 40 videos
so you you've passed that first stage of
having you know the initial passion
figuring out whether it's going to work
or not and you've already had some
successes you know there's a few videos
that have got into the triple digits as
well hundreds of views which is good to
see
channel banner looks fairly solid i like
the idea of this value proposition your
own space it kind of indicates to the
viewer that this is the kind of setup
that you could potentially have have in
your own home so it's for a target
audience of people not necessarily going
to
a gym but actually setting up a gym in
their own house so i think that's a good
way to differentiate yourself from the
rest of the audience that you may be
trying to appeal to
my question would be just from a general
thumbnail point of view is that
occasionally i don't have that
instinctive recognition of what i'm
gonna get when i watch one of these
videos for example i see that you tried
to do something quite
in ingenious here or inventive but as i
look at the sun burning down on a person
is it because you're sweating here or is
it some other thing like is it how to
cool down in in your gym space but i'm
not sure from the title so i think
you've almost over fought this one i'm
losing a little bit in translation so
sometimes
when the thumbnails and the titles are a
little too clever it actually detracts
from the viewer's ability to understand
what's going on i remember nolan on a
video
on think media a while ago said that um
in research done on netflix a viewer is
going to spend 1.8 seconds looking at a
thumbnail and then move on to the next
it's probably even less on youtube
because there are so many thumbnails to
try and contend with so think about how
you're going to get that instinctive
a-ha moment from the viewer and whether
or not they want to click but generally
speaking heather things look good here
they're testing out um shorts as well
which i'm encouraged to see
and there's a mix between the type of
equipment that you should be using in
your gym and also how it can improve
your fitness as well
amazing i hope that was a great review
for you i'm going to jump into our next
one which is going to be mama nurse
and mama nurse first off i know what you
are i know what you're doing you are a
mom who is a nurse so i think that's
great you say heart of a mom skills of a
nurse so i really like that you have uh
that part already set up on your channel
you are already past that
1 000 um
1 000 subscribers and when i come over
to your about page i really do like that
you've already built this out so i think
it's really great and you are also
committing to your upload times which is
fabulous um you're committing to those
upload times happening uh on tuesday at
nine uh nine am
uh
mountain time and uh last thing on here
uh you are cruising almost to the point
where you can get started with your
monetizing i see that you just started
your channel last year you're coming up
on a year so i want to congratulate you
on a year's worth of content now i see
that you definitely went into the shorts
game um and i understand busy mom busy
life so shorts can be a great way to do
that i'm going to challenge you on your
titles though um because when i look at
like evening walk christmas lights uh
that actually isn't nursing so that all
actually isn't motherhood so uh when i
think about the types of videos that
you're making versus the value
proposition that you've given on your
channel those to me seem a little bit
off so when i uh was looking at some of
your best videos when i go up here and i
search just uh sort videos most popular
videos um when you actually are
providing a specific value for someone
meaning you're answering a specific
question that's going to help someone in
their journey wouldn't you know that
that is your most popular video so your
most popular video is about
producing breast milk and power pumping
to increase milk
and you're showing this here if people
can see this is a before and after this
is a progression style video and you're
answering a specific question someone
has the need to understand how to
increase the milk supply and that is the
need that your video has helped them
with now
i'm not sure which direction you want to
go in terms of nursing specifically but
even if you are an ic
icu nurse i'm over here on vid iq and if
you just want to see some of the videos
you could be making i see you nurse
i just want you to see some title
recommendations how to become an a nurse
in the icu five things i learned about
nursing when i became an icu nurse how
to get started as an icu nurse interview
with an icu nurse now i'm just taking
that one
uh keyword term because i see that you
are a nurse and i was just going deeper
on that and if that is the direction you
want to go i highly recommend
that you start using that vid iq tool to
get some title and keyword generation
happening uh for your channel now i do
see that some of your top performing
videos though are on uh being a mom
and so if you want to go that route and
you want to help young mothers then
again you would need to search different
titles but i'm telling you there is a
massive opportunity for you especially
as a nurse to be helping other women
other men learn how to become nurses as
well um i would say also this is a great
shot of you so i can see who you are um
i would say let's make that even
brighter like let's bring it in more so
i can see your eyes your avatar picture
so i can see your eyes a little bit more
and then uh lastly
remember you can customize your home
screen so i am not a subscriber what
would you want my first video to see so
if you come over here and you go over to
let's say like vid iq if i were to go to
their actual home screen on their
channel you can see here that there is a
video that i can actually see right at
the very top so you can be customizing
that home page
all right well that was that review rob
who do you have
next up we have
t
rus reaction that's how i'm going to
pronounce your channel name i apologize
if i'm not getting the pronunciation
right there but look at this ever we
have a channel that started 12 days ago
so brand new to youtube and look at how
much content they've already pushed out
clearly a lot of passion determination
and effort there and for a channel
that's only 12 days old 33 subscribers
videos with hundreds of views already
you're already making custom thumbnails
there's already a lot of success and
things to celebrate here so anything
that i'm gonna suggest
i'd almost be suggesting to a channel
that's six months down the right down
the line or you know 12 months into this
i'll start with a channel banner every
day at 12 p.m
there's two questions i would ask here
first of all
what's your channel about because this
doesn't tell me anything about your
channel and you're committing to a
pretty strict schedule there which means
that you're going to making a lot of
content and i would feel that right now
viewers probably aren't that interested
in your schedule uh i think they're
probably more interested in what you
have to offer the viewer so if you want
to carry on publishing videos every
single day that's fine but this channel
banner almost kind of holds you to
account to that and it may mean that you
know in two or three months you start
seeing to feel a little bit of pressure
and stress because yeah feel as if
you're pressured to make a video every
single day so for me personally i'll be
concentrating more on a channel banner
that tells the viewers what your channel
is going to be about now in the
thumbnails and the titles it seems
fairly obviously straightforward that
you are reacting to things on youtube
whether it be reacting to mr beast
reacting to the largest oreo or
what seems to be movie trailers game
trailers
this is all good stuff for you to
practice and get a better understanding
of what reaction content really works
for your audience i think at some point
you're probably gonna have to make a
decision about what type of reaction
content works best for my audience
whether it is reacting to
fellow youtubers whether it is reacting
to
movie releases video game releases i
don't think you need to make that
decision just yet i think you probably
need more data maybe another 25 50
videos but i reckon at some point you're
gonna have to say let's start by most
popular and say ah yeah it's the
particular videos uh about movie
releases that are far more successful
than ones about reacting to uh the
fastest um workers for example down here
which only has 47 views you're going to
start to see spiky views as you have
more of an audience returning to your
content
now thumbnails as i said you're making
custom thumbnails which are excellent to
see already
you know only 12 days into your youtube
journey what i will suggest is that they
are a little bit busy at this point you
have your own youtuber reaction and then
sometimes you have a fellow youtubers
reaction and everything is what i would
call brought to the front of your
thumbnails at some point you want to
start to think about
leading the eye of a potential viewer if
they're watching from left to right top
to bottom
what is the focal point of your
thumbnail and that might mean blurring
out the background a little bit or
removing some of the elements just to
make sure
that there's an instinctive association
with the content that you're trying to
promote but generally speaking for a
channel that's only two weeks old you're
already practicing with shorts you've
already got a couple of videos which
have hundreds of views i wouldn't be
surprised if you have a hundred
subscribers within your first month if
not certainly the first two months so
congratulations on your start there
t-ra's reaction
really awesome i love seeing new
channels rob i love seeing people come
into the platform starting their
channels and growing them just like
steve steve is growing his channel steve
welcome to the show and man this is such
a critical a skill that people need to
learn and steve from reading your uh bio
i actually don't know how long you've
been doing this steve so one thing i
would recommend that you build out is
your about page how can you build
authority how can you give a little bit
about who you are so that if someone
were to click on your videos click
through to your actual channel they
could get more for who you are and what
you're doing so i would build this out
um so that people have
more options to
engage with you a little bit more as
well as up here on the very top i see
some new um youtube creators do this
this is a really critical place to be
able to put your actual
uh um website or to put your social
information so if you have an instagram
or a linkedin or something you want to
actually send people to or a link like
over here at think media we actually
send people right now we're sending them
to um grow with video live so if you'll
notice here oh no sorry free web class
because we have a web class that we're
doing so this year when you click on it
actually takes you over to our most
current web class um which i need to get
updated that that clicker look at us in
real time um but also it goes right over
to instagram and you have a lot more uh
space up here to actually be sending
people to another place so i want you to
build out this about page steve and i
want you to build out this little part
right here in terms of your videos i do
love that you are using bright colors
bright colors are really great for
youtube and um this one this one
performed really well this has a
thousand views in one month grab their
attention faster and i can tell uh let's
just look at it really quick
all right
bam there was a change did you see that
and there's a change see that those
that's keeping people's attention all
these little pieces that you're doing
right here steve it's grabbing people's
attention so it's keeping it moving it's
keeping this one going and uh and that
seems to be a great uh
angle that people in the communication
space are looking um are looking for so
i would say that uh some of your
thumbnails do actually feel a little
busy to me um and i understand you're
just doing a couple
of the uh words on it in your face
here's the other thing
do you know that actually faceless um
faceless
like this one thumbnails those can
actually perform well too so you don't
feel like you always have to have a a
lot of uh
words on your actual thumbnail if i were
to go over here and see your most
popular video um looks like you just
jumped back on the platform and your
shorts are performing much better so
keep at that if that's part of your
whole strategy
which looks like it is it's part of your
strategy for what you're doing on
youtube and i think steve that in a year
from now you're gonna see massive
progress as you go deeper another thing
i did is i went over here to the vid iq
tool i typed in the keyword
communication skills now here's the
thing um
sometimes sometimes even that language
would be
even more advanced like i'm not typing
into the communication bar uh
uh
commun like how to increase my
communication skills i'm i'm typing
things like how to prepare a talk on
stage i'm just giving you some ideas
public speaking okay so maybe i'm saying
it the public speaking presentation
skills um so be be playing on other
words also that may not just be
communication skills a fear of public
speaking i think you should make that
video uh and i think that you are on the
rise for what you're doing he said i
started the day after rob told us about
them okay great i'm excited that you are
making those shorts and rob has a whole
video on shorts actually so you can go
over to vidiq and watch that video if
you have questions about how to do
shorts
it still makes me feel really
uncomfortable when people say i did
something after what rob told me to do
oh or somebody actually watched my video
and took my advice it still
feels quite strange sometimes yeah i i
feel the same way sometimes when people
also know more about me than i think
they do i'm like that's that's
interesting did i say that in a video
yeah that's always fun all right who do
you have up next rob next channel is the
nerf reports i just instinctively
thought when i was clicking on it that
we're gonna see uh reviews of toy guns
but it's not it's about gaming as far as
i can tell congratulations on 10 000
subscribers i think that should unlock
most of the youtube tools for you
including youtube stories i think is
still at 10 000 subscribers so maybe
experiment with that if you haven't
already done so
i feel as if this channel may have a
problem and challenge not necessarily in
its own making when i saw it by most
popular i can see
that they have been successful when
they've covered topics that maybe the
mainstream media
have not talked about enough or have
abandoned for example google stadia and
apparently amazon luna is that a
cloud-based gaming service from amazon i
didn't even know about that it's
probably why it has so many views but of
course that was from over a year ago and
six months ago i am assuming that's not
a topic that's been talked about by
anyone now
and i think google stadia as far as i
understand it is kind of going the same
way it's not really been successful as a
gaming platform but
you traditionally had an audience who
was interested in that topic so whenever
i see you
making content about uh google stadia
you seem to get slightly more views i'm
sure i saw a couple here with uh 4000
views like this one here which is kind
of like an outlier for your channel but
then i think you also realize that you
need to branch out into other topics and
it feels as if what you're trying to do
is branch out
out into
alternative
based gaming platforms which i think is
a good crossover for your audience but
this is kind of resulting in spiky views
here and there you know you get 4000
views for that stadia video but then a
thousand videos for something about xbox
cloud gaming 600 views
so i think you're always going to have
this challenge really of trying to find
your
target audience for your cloud-based
gaming content and also the other
challenge you have is that i think you
describe yourself as a news gaming
outlet well that puts you in direct
competition against massive gaming
channels such as ign gamespots who
probably have earlier access to this
type of stuff and they can cover it in
more comprehensive detail than just the
solo creator you are so the question
then needs to be how can you make your
content
different
unique better
at the moment just from the thumbnails
themselves i'm not seeing a strong
enough reason to click on the thumbnails
you often use this thumbnail of showing
the the screen of a tablet
and then nothing else to really support
the evidence that you're talking about
here you kind of say it in the title
like stadia players receive exclusive
features but the first thing i'm going
to see when i'm scrolling through my
feed is this thumbnail and this
thumbnail doesn't really tease anything
about the free or exclusive features i'm
gonna see it's just a tablet with some
screens that are very difficult to see
so thumbnail wise i think you need to be
more simplistic you know use a more
simplistic element that tells me a
little bit more about the video that
you're talking about and the incentive
for me to click on
but generally speaking you know for a
channel of 10 000 subscribers the view
counts are relatively healthy you know
about a thousand views isn't too bad but
then there are some videos that get more
views some videos that get less views
and i'm not really seeing any breakout
pieces of content here so
what i would be focusing on is
definitely your thumbnails and then
really trying to find that ideal target
audience for cloud-based gaming and i
feel as if
as an example here the one about fifa
sticks i feel as if that's a bit too
much outside of what your potential
niche is for your channel but that is
the nerf report there
yeah i thought the same thing rob when i
saw it i was like nerf report all right
cool this will be all about like nerf
guns and all those kind of things too so
i thought the same thing maybe a a
change in that um
direction of channel as well so uh i
have another a channel review that's
coming up but before we do that rob um i
want to thank you for being on the show
today uh this is actually brought to you
by vidiq and i would love rob i'm gonna
get the little banner that goes on here
for us for vid iq um but you know i
think it's really important to know that
vid iq is one of the best tools that we
use here at think media when it comes to
figuring out what videos we should be
doing like what videos do we want to be
making how should we be uh how should we
be figuring out the titles and the
keywords and those types of things and
rob we've had you on the show several
times to talk about some of those
different features um but i would love
for you to share maybe your favorite
feature when it comes to vid iq
and and why because not only are you um
part of the vidiq team you're making
videos you are in the trenches making
videos with us every single week so tell
us a little bit about some of your
favorite features with vidiq oh you put
me on the spot there a little bit
heather but when i'm asked this the
default answer always for me and it's
the simplest tool i have to be honest
it is the um real-time stats bar that
you see on every single um page uh so if
you share my screen for a second i can
very quickly demonstrate what it is like
i'm looking at the nerf report still but
i'm always interested to know what's
going on on my own channel at any given
point and i can see that right now our
channel is getting three and a half
thousand views per hour and we have um
117 000 views over the last 20 48 hours
but i can add more detail to this i've
got all of these extra stats and i can
go as in-depth as telling me how many
subscribers i have and the reason i love
this is because it's everywhere it means
that i don't have to go into a youtube
studio to get this instinctive data i
don't have to pull out my phone and
check out the youtube studio wherever i
am on youtube i love this tool it's one
of the oldest tools and it's the free
tool as well which helps for you to get
started on vid iq so put me on the spot
i think that would be my answer to my
favorite tool but then when you want to
do a bit more research onto somebody
else's videos
we were just talking about this before
we went live the video scorecard down
the right hand side
this gives you a plethora of data about
why a channel has successful videos or
not first of all you may encounter a
video without actually seeing the
thumbnail whether it's from an external
link or you've been watching a video for
20 minutes you can't remember what the
thumbnail looks like you may want to
remind yourself this video is really
good why did i click on it in the first
place oh it's because of this really
striking thumbnail another tool we have
is comparing views in the first 24 hours
and so what this is telling me about
this channel is that they tend to
average
between 400 and 800 off you know less
than 500 views in the first three days
two days but this video is getting a
thousand views plus in the first two
days so it tells me that this is a
successful video for this channel
maybe it's a trending topic maybe it's
something that's really important for
that target audience if i was operating
the same gaming niche would i want to
make a competitive video about xbox
cloud gaming as well and then there's
all sorts of stuff here we've got the
legacy tools such as if i wanted to just
steal somebody's video tags i can click
that button i've now copied all of these
tags and i can use it in one of my
videos if i wanted to and again most of
these tools are completely free so i
know however we often go into
the um more complex tools as you've
already shown in terms of the title
generator and the keyword research but
sometimes just
being on youtube and then just having
these complimentary tools appear
wherever they are i find it really
comforting and whenever i now watch
youtube on somebody else's computer i'm
like hang on where's my views per hour
why can't i see the thumbnail preview
this youtube looks naked without vid iq
that's how i sometimes describe our
all of our tools and features
i love that rob and actually one of my
favorite features that i want to show
is uh this feature right down here you
know a lot of times people are like what
should i make sure i do
when i'm uploading my video and i love
that iq literally shows us exactly what
we should be doing we should be uh right
over here tags title description cards
so the the channel that i'm gonna review
next um we don't have any end card or we
don't have any cards that are loaded up
here also being able to share it on
facebook and do you have a pinned
comment happening so i love that there's
this little checklist of things to make
sure that you're doing and the reason
you want to do all this is because you
want to give the youtube algorithm as
much information as you can about
exactly what this video is and how they
can
keep people on the platform that's their
goal is to get eyeballs to the platform
and keep people on the platform and so
they i love that we have this checklist
uh piece here um for it and that's
probably one of my favorite things other
than some of the other tools that you've
already described on there i also love
to see how many views per hours are
happening it makes me feel great when i
know that people are watching videos
that we um that we've created and it's
so cool to be able to see other people's
videos as well
yeah and i think stick around for that
and optimization checklist i think we're
actively upgrading it as we speak so in
a couple of months it may be even more
valuable
i love that well uh we are uh five days
away from grow with video live i am so
excited rob is actually one of our
speakers at growth video live vidiq is
one of our main sponsors for growth
video live this is happening in las
vegas
in just a few short days and you can
actually get your ticket to this event
if you go to
growethvideolive.com and if you want to
upgrade to our platinum experience which
gets you all of the things happening at
uh growth video live you can go to
gwvlplatinum.com
i'm gonna take a sip of water rob and
i'm gonna play this short video so
people can see what this conference is
going to be about and then we'll jump
back into some q a and then some
additional channel reviews this thing
is your gateway to get out of the thing
that you complain about but people would
rather complain about how it is then put
in the work we need to start
understanding how big this opportunity
is because for everybody in this room he
will sit back in 20 30 years and regret
if you didn't execute in this era it has
never been a better time in the human
race ever to actually just go all in on
you
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world you're
not betting on this you're finished
[Music]
this is your golden era right now
there's never been a better time to be
here
[Music]
this is the greatest golden era of not
only business but life
i desperately want you to win
but this is on you
[Music]
grow with video live happening in just a
few short days i saw someone that says
oh man i can't make it in person no
worries you can actually jump over here
and you can get access to our virtual um
all access pass we have it happening
virtually for you as well as in person
rob's actually joining us virtually too
he can't make it in person so he's
coming virtual this year um so make sure
you grab your tickets to growth video
live i am so excited for all of the main
speakers i'm excited for the networking
and tickets are actually almost sold out
we actually had to move rooms because we
initially sold out all the tickets and
we have people still buying tickets to
the in person so we've actually moved
rooms crazy what's happening but so many
people are coming to las vegas if you
can't make it in the room though you
definitely can come uh online and we
have two different options for you
online as well all right let's jump into
a quick q a segment rob we'll shift our
focus and then we'll come back into um
doing some channel reviews nora asks
what should be in the description and
the tags rob
okay so
my advance and answer to this and i
apologize in advance is if you are
worrying about descriptions and tags
you are worrying about the wrong things
on youtube in 2022
whatever
time and effort you want to spend on
those descriptions and tags
take it all and put it in your
video title
your
thumbnail and the first 15 seconds of
your content because
99
of what's gonna tell youtube whether
your content satisfies the viewer is
that
now having said that if you still want
to focus on the description
then i would focus on the
what's called above the fold part of the
description you know the first couple of
lines that somebody's going to see when
they are searching for your content
and then
think about
any calls to action so if you're wanting
to sell products and services or you
want in people to download a free
workbook or something that you're
providing make sure you include that uh
content as well but try and keep it
simple i know you have 5 000
characters in your description but who
actually reads all of that
tags
i really i really don't want to waste
any time on tags as i've said all i
would do is
search
for
what you want to rank for and whatever
the top video is copy their tags paste
it into your video tag box using vidiq's
free tool then remove the tags that you
don't think are necessary add a couple
more but really only spend like a minute
or less on that i mean that's my opinion
uh what do you think on on
on i guess search engine optimization at
this stage in 2022 heather yeah i think
that you definitely there is a priority
like you said rob there's a priority of
what you should be focused on and your
title and thumbnail and topic should be
top priority and then the other pieces
um can be filled in and what i love so
much about the different tools that
youtube and vidiq offer is um there you
can actually put in uh a template into
your youtube description that's just the
one that happens on all of them and all
you have to do is change the top line so
we have a template that goes on every
one of our videos and we just change out
a few things rather than having to type
out everything that happens on that um
and then i think what's great about
keywords uh and tags is it's actually
better for your benefit of researching
what your topic is and knowing what your
video is about uh to be able to do that
but i completely agree rob i think it's
best to give as much data as you can but
focus on the key three t's first your
topic your title and your thumbnail
before anything else because whether you
feed the information to the algorithm or
not it's not going to do anything if
those three things are not locked and on
point already
all right um what rob do you count as an
i what are good colors for eye-catching
thumbnails
so
we did some data analysis on this uh
quite a while ago actually i remember we
were doing some talks based on what the
the most popular colors and surprisingly
it was whites blacks and grays that
tended to be
the most striking
for
viewers
i don't know if that's because it
contrasted really well with light and
dark mode on youtube and how accurate
that is in 2022 again is uh debatable i
think what i would stress
is
whatever color scheme you decide to
adopt
make sure that
there's one or two striking colors that
contrast well i think there's a tool
called the adobe color wheel where you
can actually set a color and it will
tell you what colors contrast really
well with it and
i always advise no more than three
dominant colors in your thumbnails
because the more colors there are the
more muddy the thumbnail gets when it's
shrunken down to the postage stamp size
that most viewers see at remember you
will um
design your thumbnail on a 34-inch
widescreen monitor and everybody will
see it you know one inch by one inch on
a mobile phone so really do consider
that um
so yeah
and it really does depend another thing
to consider is your topic gaming
channels you're probably thinking about
really bright fluorescent greens and
blues and whatnot
but on the other hand you may want to
consider colors that contrast completely
with other channels in your niche for
example uh brian g johnson who's in our
youtube niche he used to use like vomit
green colors
because they really stood out when
people were searching for how to get
more subscribers and more views and so
something that contrasts completely with
other channels can really be beneficial
as well
great great answer all right last one
last one uh
channel um
i'm the top channel in my niche but what
to do now the growth channels uh tell
you how to get authority and topping
your niche but then advice stops there
for those of us who have made it
well i'm going to answer this one and
i'm going to say that there is always
more opportunity for growth even if you
are the industry leader and i would say
you're talking to two companies that are
the industry leaders in our space and we
are still growing and we are still
learning um there is more influence that
can be made out there for you and i
would actually recommend that you start
thinking business-wise so you've grown
your youtube channel but i'd be
interested to know in this racing videos
um all for him racing videos what's the
business look like you know you can't
take your subscribers to the bank right
you know you can't take your likes to
the bank right so i would really be uh
thinking about even though you're
growing your youtube channel and you're
at the top of your niche there how can
you be expanding out your business
what's the business model wrapped around
that we're teaching all about that
growth video live this year we've got
some heavy hitters in the room that are
going to be in the audience as well as
on stage talking about how they are
maximizing their business and we have
someone like pace morby who has over 300
million dollars in assets because of
learning how to leverage his personal
brand and his youtube channel and he's
in the top of his industry um and how
he's been able to grow the other side so
yes youtube you might be in the top of
your niche but what does that look like
for you business-wise and where you're
expanding beyond that so i'd recommend
you get in the room at growth video live
either virtually or in person uh for
that all right rob let's transition back
over to our channel reviews i'll start
with this one i've got uh i think it's
michaela mckayla uh
and here is her beautiful channel
um first off i do definitely love the
artwork that you have at the top of that
let me move these banners off um i love
the the artwork that you have at the top
of this and here's my advice
for review channels now my background
definitely is um from the business side
i
grew up in digital marketing grew up
meaning like as an adult i did digital
marketing i've been in the advertising
space and my mind really does focus on
as you're growing influence how are you
monetizing that how are you growing that
because uh if you don't have a business
model idea wrapped around your youtube
channel then you basically just have a
very expensive hobby and i don't want
you to have a very expensive hobby i
want you to be generating real income
off of what you're doing and my thing
about reaction channels is that it's
very much consistent or or very much
leans on that it has to be views views
are one of the ways that you could be
making money which is through your
adsense and my only thing about when
people start reaction channels is one
where do you want this to go so i would
just want to ask you even though you
like doing reaction channels i'm not
trying to tell you not to but here just
hear me out as your coach here
even though you might like to do
reaction style content do you want to
still be doing that in three years
like what if if this is the only thing
you were doing on youtube would you want
this to be what you're doing in three
years if it is yes and you love movies
and you love reacting to tv and you love
doing this and you want to maybe grow a
patreon uh service or a youtube
membership or you want to do brand deals
that are associated with it that's fine
but a lot of times when i'm talking to
people who start reaction channels like
you have uh the they they actually don't
know how they want to make this into a
business and they burn out so my advice
to you is just really be thinking about
where you want this to go i think that
entertainment channels in general on
youtube are fascinating i love that
there are so many people that can be
creative and can share their personality
and what that looks like for them but i
just want to ask you to be thinking
about that as a
little nugget in the back of your head
when you're doing a channel like this i
see that you did start this channel in
2010 um and this is kind of something
you've been back and forth with and so
that's why i wanted to challenge you
specifically on uh this one first off
when i look at your titles um i'm not
sure why there's two different languages
here um on youtube you definitely don't
have to do two different languages you
can keep that in a singular language on
youtube because most people will watch
or search youtube with their native
language um if that's the type of
content that they are
that they're moving uh that they're that
they're consuming um i would also say
too that uh your thumbnails um
to me i definitely like that you're
doing this pink behind them uh it
definitely feels very busy and i know
that this is kind of in the realm of uh
what reaction channels do they
definitely have more of that busy feel
to it but there's a there's a lot
happening uh when i'm seeing these
different thumbnails that doesn't mean
it's not working i just want you to know
it feels very busy and things like
episode one episode two episode three um
those don't have to be on there they
don't have to be on the thumbnail you
could actually take those all the way
off and it could be a little bit
it could be a little bit better so i do
love that you're doing the sounding
music and you did see that there was
traction this has almost 5 000 views so
you made another one and you made
another one so i want to compliment you
on when you see success success leaves
clues so make part twos and she made not
just a part two but also a part three so
can we give her uh some some love in the
comments for going all in on that um
also when you are doing these types of
reaction style uh contents now here
let's look at this this thumbnail
i can see why this thumbnail he finally
said it and like it's you it's him
you're smiling it's one person it makes
sense this thumbnail to me makes sense
like even these ones seem a lot cleaner
than your newest one see how see how
your newest one has a lot happening
you're over like this these other three
people not saying it's bad it just said
this is what i'm noticing when i'm
looking at what's winning for your
channel so i go to most popular videos
here and um
when it comes to reaction it's all about
trend surfing trend serving trend
surfing trend surfing and i see that
that is what you're doing you're riding
the trend and i'd say go deeper you can
talk about this 17 different ways you
could talk about this one 17 different
ways like there's a lot that can happen
um you can also create shorts out of
this so you could be pulling the uh what
i call the key moments out of these
videos that are winning and make a short
out of them as well and that can help
you increase your views lastly again
let's get that uh built out a little bit
more on your description of your about
page and right up here at the top it
just says ig
i already know it's instagram so you
could actually use this space for a
little bit more uh so that i know where
i'm going i know it's instagram but if
you want to use a website or you want to
send people to a merch site or something
like that
you can use that for those purposes also
all right rob
how do you feel about reaction channels
um
i i
the moment somebody says a reaction
channel um the question we most often
get asked is how do i avoid copyright
issues with reaction channels um i'm
always on the technical side of it in
that you know make sure it's
transformational make sure you're adding
your own voice and you're being unique
to it um
but
reaction channels can be very very
successful i mean
the biggest goldmine of reaction content
over the last week week and a half has
been the johnny depp amber heard thing
like oh yeah there's channels that have
just blown up i don't know if you you're
aware of emily d baker she's a lawyer
this stuff her channel has grown by
hundreds of thousands of subscribers in
the last couple of weeks because of her
knowledge and her ability to react to it
so
they can be very successful you've just
got to make sure you understand the
youtube guidelines so that you're not uh
stepping onto the line of copyright
material or reuse content um and they
just want to mention something as well
uh heather you know we just answered a
question about um colors and thumbnails
and when you showed the most popular one
on that channel that we were just
looking at the colors were very striking
i think it was orange and blue and pink
and as you say these recent thumbnails
are a bit too muddy a bit too
complicated but that most popular one
that's a really good example of simple
use of a couple of dominant
colors in the thumbnails it's really
going to help the viewer
get to understand what what they're
getting into if they click on a video
and even this one too she even though
it's a dark background dark background
she put that pink around her which pops
a little bit more and makes even just
the difference there too so these are
subtle differences
that really make a difference when you
look at those thumbnails versus your
latest thumbnails
yeah it looks as if she's trying to
include text
as well and maybe
that's adding too much because like
where are you putting the text you're
putting a text usually over the thing
you're reacting to so maybe something's
got to give there
or at least experiment that's all i i
will always say that i mean
you don't know if it's going to be right
or wrong until you experiment
all right well uh thank you so much for
the super chat um and we love that
you're here listening to the reviews
that's amazing so i wanted to ask that
question about reaction channels because
i saw that super chat come in and i
thought might as well all right rob who
do you have up next we have terran daly
up next congratulations on a thousand
subscribers
you describe your channel very simply
and in a minimalist fashion
self-transformation
okay that's fine my question to you
would be
self-transforming what
and for whom like is it the
20-something
uh female who is in their second job
they're climbing up the career ladder
they're earning fifty thousand dollars
to seventy five thousand dollars uh a
year and they want to
become a manager or a leader or they
want to lose a little bit of weight or
know how to
make themselves more professional and
presentable in a corporate environment i
know we sound like really specific
things but what we're trying to do here
is create your ideal avatar your ideal
viewer who when when they watch one of
your videos
they know what to expect when they come
back to your next piece of content maybe
you've already done that i just didn't
see it too much in the channel banner
and then in the videos themselves
because you're moving from your natural
hair care routine to morning fitness
to
then uh how to straighten your hair and
these are all
somewhat connected um topics but as a
smaller channel usually you find your
strength in a particular niche and then
branch out from there because the big
question is right now
is
do i care about this creator and when
you're a smaller channel that can be
much harder to convince your viewers but
as you grow an audience and you take
them on a journey then they'll start to
care more about you and then you can
take them on journeys wherever you want
when i sort by most popular right now it
seems to suggest that you have a
strength in how to look after your hair
and i guess what stair master steps
that's a fitness routine as well what i
would also be looking at here is the
length of time between your successful
videos
two mum two years ago six months ago 11
months ago what i would be thinking
about doing is actually re-making these
pieces of content
but with
more knowledge of a topic and being a
better content creator
because these are your gateway videos
right now i can see on this one thanks
to vidiq's tool that 13 views per hour
there's still you know 200 people
watching this video every single day
what would be the next natural
step in progression of that video that's
presented here and then
going back to the lowest common
denominator unfortunately you haven't
been able to commit to a level of
consistency for the last couple of
months because you've only made two
videos in the last four months so
another thing that i would be
encouraging you to do is say to yourself
i'm gonna make at least one video every
two weeks for the next three to six
months so that i can create a stable and
consistent schedule because
unfortunately where you are at the
moment
and the topic that you're covering
and this may be hard to take but unless
you're a completely unique creator and
you can provide something completely new
fresh and unique
you are replaceable because your
audience wants more from you and you
haven't been able to deliver that and
because of that youtube is going to be
finding alternative channels but are
posting on a more regular basis
it is a real
tough
catch-22 situation
whereby we don't want you to make
too much content and burn yourself out
but at the same time your viewers in
youtube are not going to wait for you to
make your next video if you haven't done
it for a couple of weeks and they'll
find alternative content so yeah
sticking to a bit of consistency over
the next couple of months will be my
advice as well
that is key in order to grow on youtube
you have to post those videos on youtube
so thank you for that uh review that you
just did i am so excited uh because i'm
gonna be reviewing chris davis
he's been in our community for uh quite
some time and i'm excited because chris
passed that 10 000 subscriber mark so
can we give him a shout out inside of
the chat because what an accomplishment
and approaching that one million views
that's so incredible so congratulations
chris chris is doing all things trumpet
lessons so really excited because this
is a great niche to be in because you
are helping people with a specific
problem and music and understanding how
to do music understanding trumpets
specifically is a really really great
place to be um and
why i say that is because this is not um
this is music is here music is musicians
are here and so i love that you are
doing that congratulations uh for
getting there and i wanted to show um
this is just kind of for the audience
chris and then i'll get to your review
but i wanted to show why i say
you should be making these same videos
again now you might be thinking well i
already made that video heather i know
you did but let me just show you
using chris as an example of why you
should remake videos every single year
the videos that are winning you should
remake every single year so chris did
this video right here called how to buzz
a trumpet mouthpiece and you'll notice i
mean i'm just gonna call you out chris
we're not really like great on the
thumbnail i mean even if we click on the
video this is i mean he's in his music
class here in his studio um and this is
not necessarily the best angle this
isn't necessarily the best quality light
is behind him not in front of him i mean
i'm just calling him out because i know
him okay but here's what i want to show
you uh here on the show he did how to
buzz a trumpet mouthpiece now if i were
to put that here how to buzz a
trumpet
uh mouthpiece
when i do this look at what chris has
done not only did he make that one video
that got a hundred and fifty three
thousand views five years ago over the
last five years but then he also classed
it up a year ago and made that same
exact video how to buzz a trumpet
mouthpiece and look what he added five
tips to make it easier for you that
video has 10 000 views and wouldn't you
know he did another one that says play
trumpet without buzzing lips so he's
going on another angle of that same
exact video so i just want you to know
that making the same video over and over
in a different way is like putting hooks
in the ocean you don't know what fish
you're gonna catch right and so you want
to put as many hooks in the ocean as you
can now chris i think you're doing a
fabulous job on your youtube channel um
i know that i have uh reviewed this one
before and i would say your thumbnails
are great if you'll notice the use of
color that he has here he's doing a
great job with um with this part of what
he's doing i would uh
go deeper chris into your vid iq and
figuring out um other keywords you could
be hitting but i understand that this
isn't like
the the amount of people that are
interested in trumpets is not the same
amount of people that are interested in
purchasing homes if that makes sense so
your market cap is different so
one thing i want to actually address
chris not even here on your channel but
actually where am i going next so if i
look at your description i don't have
any information about why i should
believe you why i should follow you any
of those pieces here but what i do love
is that we actually have this trumpet
lessons hq site and we have a free
download so he's he's got a business
model wrapped around what he's doing
over here on youtube which is great
because that's sending people into
collecting their emails so he could be
building an email list and growing his
influence off of youtube i'll also say
to chris looking at the videos that
you're producing i do love that you have
this one little light behind you but
this is still very dark so i i would
love if you could maybe put a little bit
more light in the front of you so
there's more um more
distance in the foreground and the
background of the um
of the video that you're doing but i
mean let's just look at it here guys all
the way through single shot and he's
just doing a little bit of editing
that's working on his channel and then
you get all the way to the end and he
sends you to the next video so um i
would say chris review-wise keep up the
good work um if there's something i
would actually update it would be your
uh landing pages because this to me
needs more information this to me needs
more information um and that is a more
advanced review for chris
what do you have next rob
okay the next channel we have just bear
me one second because i think i've
copied it over by accident so i just
need to grab it again
no worries
right
um
yeah i was messing around with links in
the background
and that classic thing where oh
i've got this tab and i've accidentally
searched for something on that tab okay
i'm ready so the next channel we have is
pretty lucky and they are approaching
200 subscribers and just instinctively
from the channel banner and the
thumbnails
it looks as if you focus on roller
coaster
rides at theme parks which
is a niche but i know that it can be
quite a competitive niche um and it's
interesting that it's one of those
topics that's probably now going to get
more popular again as the pandemic
lockdown ends and people are allowed to
travel freely again
gotta credit you on your thumbnails i
think you try your best to show
the ride in motion and the excitement of
it especially this one like you're in
the middle of a ride and
you've also named it and
it is one of those interesting aspects
where
do you have to tell the viewer what the
quality of the video is and i think in
this circumstance where it's when it's a
ride and also when you're doing street
tours of cities people like that um
concept of it being in a very high
quality so i think that's a good idea as
well
i guess a question would be
why are some videos getting more views
than others because we see the ones at
sea world
uh have 300 plus views whereas the ones
at uh oh actually they're all at sea
world as well so that's interesting why
do some videos get more views and i'm
wondering if it's a
thumbnail choice here whether
these thumbnails
of a certain design are more effective
for your audience than these ones i mean
i personally would argue that these are
better thumbnails but
the proof is always in the testing and
it would seem to suggest that a certain
thumbnail style is working better for
your audience i'm also curious to know
how long you've been on youtube
and the answer seems to be a couple of
years although
i think as with many travel style
location style channels
it's been a while for you to get back
into the swing of things and it looks as
if you really started to kick off with
videos uh three or four months ago yeah
i would say
this
4k pov is a little too intrusive on the
thumbnails it feels a bit like a massive
channel logo and it can be a bit
distracting
on some of these
and then my final question would be
what makes a viewer excited to click
on a roller coaster video because i know
there's a lot of examples of this on
youtube and i probably have to do a
quick search for this this is going to
be a very
simple
search
um but i'm wondering
if uh the whatever biggest channel show
and it looks to be
the moment of chia terror you know that
front forward point of view i'm about to
go down a big drop or on a big bend or
twist
and some of these don't actually have
the
rider's reaction
so maybe it's the right it's wow that is
i mean if that's not gonna make you
click on a thumbnail i don't know what
isn't that's truly terrifying um but
yeah it looks to me as if the ride
is the the most important part of the
thumbnail as opposed to perhaps your
reaction to it and yeah these as i look
at these thumbnails now again they're
perhaps a little bit too busy we want to
see that moment of dread and fear
because that's what the viewer wants to
get into if they're searching for this
type of content but again going back to
basics under 200 subscribers
view counts typically in the hundreds
that's an encouraging start for the
channel
yes i love love love uh seeing channels
like that and rob some of the most
interesting channels that i'm seeing pop
on youtube lately are animal related
channels and i have two channels real
quick that i'm going to do kind of side
by side reviews of um because i i want
to show the differences of ways that
people can create content and
here at think media you know we teach 16
different content types that you could
be doing to be growing your youtube
channels and i want to start first off
with casual aquatics casual aquatics and
um i am fascinated by channels like this
because i to me it brings me back to
when i was a kid when i got to watch
like national geographic or you know
when uh animal planet came out and you
were like behind the scenes and learning
about all these animals this is like you
get to do it in real life so i think
it's really uh fun to see these
different types of channels however i
understand that your specialty might not
be designed and might not be a search
engine optimization your specialty is
understanding aquatics so here's a
couple tips that i want to give you uh
on this channel specifically number one
um i think that your thumbnails could be
a lot more engaging and
even when you're looking at like fish
specifically or you're looking at tanks
specifically um you can actually use
sites you can use free content sites to
gather
actual great pictures of these different
animals or different pieces of the
equipment that you're using or you can
actually purchase those different um
images from the uh from different paid
sites so if you know it's a specific
types of fish or something like that i
would just say for this casual aquatics
channel um i would be leveling up your
thumbnails and here's one mistake that i
do see a different content creators
making and that is not having readable
thumbnails feeding the pond and updates
number one that doesn't help me to know
what i'm looking at number two it's very
hard to read with that font style so i
think there could be a better uh picture
of the pond that can maybe help um and
there could be different styles of font
choices when you are choosing those
different pieces i would want to also
help you with some of your thumbnails um
i think that this is a
huge growing market when you think about
the aquatics in general
on youtube and i would be thinking very
specifically about the uh way that you
are titling your videos and i would be
putting more effort into that pre
uh pre-done video content meaning like
before you press record you're doing
research on your videos um because
that's gonna help you i can tell that
this one here got four thousand views
because it is hitting the actual keyword
of electric blue jack dempsey uh chit
chat chitchat i don't know how to say
that one properly but that is like
that's why that one actually is getting
views um is because of that another
aquatic channel um that i want to do a
quick review on is this one here and
this is actually what's called a niche
inside of a niche so not only is papa
shrimp about the aquatics but this
channel is all about shrimp now that to
me is fascinating because i am seeing
here that one there's 700 other people
that are massively interested in this
niche inside of a niche your people are
here they're on youtube and they're
watching your content for over an hour
that to me is fascinating so if you want
to see different types of content you
could be doing on your channel we've got
papa shrimp over here doing a podcast on
his channel for over an hour
specifically talking about shrimp with
other i'm gonna call them shrimpers i
think is what they're called sorry papa
shrimp if i'm not saying that properly
um but i think it's fascinating that you
have people joining you live that are
interested in doing what you're doing i
love that you guys are setting
yourselves up in your quote-unquote
studio and you're talking about shrimp
now here's the thing your titles could
use a lot more work so i understand that
this to me is very much a what i call an
internal video meaning that you're
giving content to your internal audience
keeping it shrimple that's hilarious but
i wouldn't know i wouldn't insert no one
would search that they would be
searching a specific title and i love
that you're celebrating milestones so
that is an internal video but even when
i go over here keeping it shrimple could
be the name of your show like this show
right here that you're on you're
watching
the grow with video live show
it is on our podcasting channel but the
title of this video was how to get views
and subscribers so we titled the video
to be enticing for the right audience to
come into the topic that we're talking
about we're talking about how to get to
your first 1000 subscribers and we're
reviewing channels that are under a
thousand subscribers so i hope that
helps you pop a shrimp to learn a little
bit more about the style of videos um
and not even that but how to title your
videos to bring people in to
your content is that fascinating rob i
mean not only aquatics but then
shrimping
yeah yeah
and a niche within a niche it's always a
good start to break out the channel but
i would agree with you heather and they
they are committing
one of the biggest
crimes any creator can do and all small
creators myself included uh were
accountable for this and that is
you'll have to watch my video virtual
presentation grow with video to find out
oh that was a great setup rob thank you
so much about that 30 seconds out of
fraser
it was so good um we are going to wrap
up with rob's last and final review if
you've not gotten your tickets to grow
with video live we want to encourage you
to go and get those tickets to grow with
video lives happening in just a few
short days uh you can get a five percent
off of all of our ticket levels and by
the way we only i i got a text while
we're on this there's like five tickets
left so if you are planning on coming to
the event you better grab your ticket
today because they we will be sold out
on this event you also do have the
option of coming virtually so you can
experience uh this from the comfort of
your own home in your office on your way
to disneyland whatever you're doing and
you need to join us for this actual
conference you can do that by getting
your ticket at growthvideolive.com
use the coupon code gwvlshow
for five percent off and if you've not
already gotten your free 30 days to bid
iq make sure you do that as well
vidiq.com forward slash think is how you
can get those 30 days rob who will be
your final uh review of the day so the
final channel again apologies i'm going
to pronounce this channel name probably
completely wrong is hero toliver
and their channel has a fifteen hundred
oh i'm her on social media
yeah here we go i've got the wrong tab
there that should work we should be good
now there we go uh so hero toliver one
and a half thousand subscribers
uh and
there are a few things that are just
jumping out to me straight away
first of all this channel banner i have
seen this channel banner
multiple times on many gaming channels
uh that the one with the racing car
something from watch dogs also
assassin's creed
so
if you use a template design then you're
not really different differentiating
yourself as a channel
but then when i go from the channel
banner to the content
i'm seeing all sorts of types of videos
what are the odds shots this looks as if
it's something to do with cars in the
real world want to see something cool i
think that's a snake and i think that
kind of sums up
where your channel is currently at like
you've found something cool on the
internet or you film something cool and
you want to show it to just anybody who
wants to watch it who may find it
interesting and without that channel
focus and that target audience then i'm
afraid what's going to happen is you're
going to have these very spiky views
some videos are getting over a thousand
views some videos are getting less than
50. and that's going to continue to
happen if you don't know who should be
watching your video from one video to
the next
you're also doing youtube shots and of
course youtube shots is a big growing
area of youtube and we can't really
assess the custom thumbnails here
because
most shots will not show their thumbnail
to a viewer but if i just go through the
titles we're looking at lunch with a
raccoon something about a card game and
then what are the odds something about
wiper blades something about a corvette
motor
if i watch one of your shorts
i wouldn't know what's coming next so
again channel focus is something that
you should really pay attention to
on your content and
the final thing i would say is
that
as well as testing shots you are doing
some um long form content um but
there's quite a big jump from going from
a
10 to 15 second shots to then a 10
minute video about mother's day gift
ideas again that seems like a very
random topic
i have a colleague here at vid iq who's
had success not only with
shorts but also
short
form
regular videos if that makes any sense
they're like 90 seconds long but they're
in a wide screen format and the delivery
and the pace is very similar so the
audience even though they're getting a
slightly longer video they kind of know
what to expect here and again from video
to video
it almost feels as if it's a new video
from a new channel every time i look at
your content so absolutely you're
publishing a lot of content
but where's the the target audience
where's the consistency who should be
watching your videos from one to the
next uh and starting to to grow a trust
and relationships uh with your viewers
so so key rob you got to say consistent
i love i saw an aha moment that was like
you got to be consistent in the right
content and that's the key is the right
content well rob thank you so much for
joining us today on the show you can get
your free uh 30 days of vid iq at vidiq
dot com forward slash think and i'll see
you at girls video live rob i can't
believe it i usually pleasure thank you
for having me on can i just do really
cheeky plug i know this is really really
really cheeky but if you just share my
screen for one second if all of you want
to raid a live stream that we currently
have going on we're doing audits with a
bit of a difference we're testing
watching the first 30 seconds of
somebody's video and deciding whether or
not we continue to watch so if you want
to learn a bit more about video content
itself head on over to vid iq
after we've had this outro but it's been
a pleasure as always thank you for
having me on heather and i look forward
to having you on doing channel audits on
the vid iq channel very soon i can't
wait i'm going to go over and check out
those because that's a fun way to do
reviews i've never done that before so
i'm going to go over and watch you guys
with my popcorn and lunch after we're
done so thanks rob um well again thank
you so much for joining us here on the
growth video live show you can get your
tickets to growth video live right now
by clicking in the description below if
you want to check out another video from
rob and heather you can click or tap the
screen right now and you can check out
one of our other reviews or if you want
to check out our podcast you can do that
by clicking or tapping the screen right
now thanks so much for watching and
we'll catch you in the next video this
thing
is your gateway to get out of the thing
that you complain about but people would
rather complain about how it is than put
in the work we need to start
understanding how big this opportunity
is because for everybody in this room he
will sit back in 20 30 years and regret
if you didn't execute in this era it has
never been a better time in the human
race ever to actually just go all in on
you
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world you're
not betting on this you're finished
[Music]
this is your golden era right now
there's never been a better time to beat
you
[Music]
this is the greatest golden era of not
only business but life
i desperately want you to win
but this is on you